oh [__] oh [__] Monday March 17th the
day the devil and some [__] chick
were buried at sea
she wouldn't suck his dick puppet what
his happy Irish day to all you bad
[__] savages
I love you without you I wouldn't even
know what balls were in it
tickly but ocean ocean yet Monday
[__]
watch that [__] let's do this [__] why
be a [__] mutt like everybody else
it's Monday [__]
what we huh why be a Jew if you ain't
gonna Rob somebody [__] it let's do this
[__] huh huh jump get up wash your [__]
clean that helmet pull this in back wash
the barnacles out of the ass somebody up
there's dying to give you a rim job take
a walk I heard somebody picked up my
Dukas in New York so Moosa damn already
I don't have to tell you what'll happen
if he becomes a government witness I can
assure you that will not be the case
yeah I assumed you were taking that
position but I am supposed to advise you
against such a Sidney relax have a crew
so to everything say that again tell me
cops all over the place there's a
million [__] sites all over Jimmy
they've got a tap on that line their
City shut your [__] mouth
listen to me dummy Forsyth knew they had
mardukas in custody or not
let me tell you two stupid [__]
something I don't want to get another
phone call just because if I don't I'm
gonna get on a [__] plane and I'm
gonna blow parts to [__] you
understand Walsh in Chicago a long time
don't say a word to me Sydney don't say
a [__] word Oh Gary this telephone in
your head you just got an earthquake in
California you heard it [__] live on
the Church of what's happening now
[__]
ginger thank you coming up more problems
for a trouble risk winner yeah we're
having an earthquake
okay it appears to have stopped we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna jump right
now to the yeah to the US Geological
Survey let's get right on that right now
that felt very close yeah let's get
right on that
that's the spirit of Dennis Farina
coming that's the spirit of Dennis
Farina who I got a little bit scared
there for a minute [__] breath away
oh [__] this is the end if that was an
adrenaline rush the [__] you
witnessed it live search of what's
happening now and we're still balls deep
[__] bait but look at the vapor tipped
over they're gonna break I'm Frank I'm
in Boston
nice to know you [__]
oh my god that I would have slept right
through that oh no I want to slip right
through that man oh [__] that's crazy